[Music]
so we're going to go over the rules of
the K I'm sorry the
guaza and um we can use you guys uh to
help clarify things so anything I miss
any questions that you guys have on it
for further
clarification um speak up okay all right
um again the idea in J Wasa it is mind
training it is Spirit
training um and it is the reconciliation
of form and nonform and so it is the
reconciliation of the two minds the
egoic mind is the for mind and the god
mind is the Transcendence of for mind
okay so that's what you're doing it's
not fighting fighting something else
sparring is something else
um
and it is not what modern contemporary
iido considers to be guaza which is
where you just pick
techniques uh beforehand so the UK comes
in and you change whatever technique
you're going to pick but you know what
technique you are you are going to do
from the get-go okay that is there's no
mind training in that
whatsoever um and there's no Recon
ilation of the two minds is just the ego
tripartite mind continuing to work it
it's just Kona is is all that is okay so
let me demonstrate real quickly what
that is what we know okay so this is not
Gaza and I I will Express aloud what I'm
doing in my mind okay so we'll do it
for and I go I'll do tenet
I'm going to doai
10 I'm GNA do
suou I'm going to
[Music]
do I'm going to do
K this is not g was that's just picking
techniques changing
them it's Kona okay it is the ego Tri
partip mind function okay that's not
what we're doing to make sure we're not
doing that we have these rules these
rules will you up sooner or later
if you're trying to do those things okay
and when they
don't just like any zen
master they're going to change it so you
can't do that okay so not a un like a
cone practice practice Master is
going to change the rules of the
engagement and you can't do your ego
tripartite mind functioning anymore so
for example someone can
DOI um and you can do that all day long
right but we might change the grips so a
Sit it like this one hand like that one
hand like that do you see and or maybe
may we were like okay uh one hand on the
collar one hand on the on the elbow or
two hands on the elbow we start changing
it and and you'll see very quickly
you're not so fluid anymore because you
were just picking techniques you're not
actually doing Gaza you're not doing
takam musiki okay all right so but these
rules generally will F you up um long
before a teacher has to play around with
things okay all right so so we'll start
with the really simple ones to
understand uh the first one is that NGA
has only four attempts they're attempts
they're not successful throws or
successful pins you get four chances to
do it and then that's it now it's the
other person's turn to be uh
nogget second rule is uh no
cupins and that is because
you are doing and relating to and being
in the
moment and uh these pins are not real
pins so for as we get on further for
example the Wasa must be real so if you
are trying to pin someone down that
means they should not be getting up but
in every one of aikido's pins which I
call CQ exercises
the UK can get up so it's not a real pin
we don't practice the coku pins in guaza
okay because the technique must be real
and
also the UK never seeks
agency when the UK decides to lay at the
bottom instead of getting up because
they can that is Seeking a agency so
that's not good that's not not allowed
okay so for example in the video that we
showed last
night
um we I think we did it from kaga as and
Sean had already had the caveat earlier
not to do this cou pin okay so to show
you that it's not a real pin Sean should
follow the yin energy that would not be
it my friend
yes there he goes okay
or he can just slide
forward and now he's off of it okay so I
corrected him by going sure let's rewind
the film a little just a little
sure here this is all good this is a
real pin okay but now take it to a break
when we came here this is your break and
tap when you don't like
it okay you could do that in the g
wasn't but you can't do a
cupin next rule the Wasa must be
real now this is going to be difficult
for a ferite because they don't know
what's real because they lack the fight
experience um so you see all kinds of
weird things so some of the uh two
things that came out two things that
came out the other day
was um Sean's version of this where I
you
turn and you're doing this this this
isn't that that will never happen in
real life he just would brace on against
that throw right there it doesn't happen
okay or uh
uh
Virginia turning behind her back kind of
thing like that doesn't happen in real
life so you're not allowed those things
okay any questions from you so far you
guys share on we on number
three the wle must be real part requires
that you
understand the basics that you've put
forth over the past few years regarding
center of gravity base of support yeah
like we we have real objective ways that
we throw that
person uh you anybody gets in those
mechanics is going to get
thrown uh as opposed to somebody that's
just doing the iido culture ukemi like a
us would go down for you on that do you
see and you let her although you laughed
you let her grab your hand on that you
see that doesn't happen in real life so
we don't we don't allow those techniques
okay
um
versus the where I threw a
us um he doesn't he he he barely trains
for he barely trains like once a week
maybe and uh he doesn't know K that's
why he's not in a
Haka
um there's just so much he doesn't know
and so I threw him and you could see his
body got picked up he got rotated in
space and he dropped down that's that's
a real mechanics that would happen to
anybody
uh is equally to someone who knows how
to fall and someone who does not know
how to fall okay so technique must be
real um hence no I tyo as well so II tyo
is when Virginia and Sean you guys
yesterday were doing the EO the EO hand
work like yeah that's in iido but that's
not in guaza okay we want to see um a
some sort of finality or conclusion to
the
engagement so if you throw
someone uh in the street they don't get
up like iido people think you you you
drop anyone from I would say knee height
they don't get up um they might not be
unconscious but ankles are thrash feet
are thrash knees are thrash it's very
very difficult to um get up now let
alone you have their body going Topsy
Turvy like you're doing shag or or Ed
nag they're not getting up they're not
getting up okay
um it's one reason why for example I
used to do the pin following edag but if
you pay attention I don't pin out of VI
Minag anymore
because why am I going to pin someone
who's unconscious do do you understand
what I'm saying so it's kind of like
when I teach the kids um not the kids or
adults but in the police
academy um if we shoot somebody body and
there's brains on the street I'm not
going to handcuff him he's already in a
position of disadvantage okay so I need
to get on to Medical I'm not going to go
officer safety let me handcuff them
before I get to Medical that that
doesn't make sense okay so as I always
tell them code blue is the greatest
position of disadvantage I don't need to
control this person anymore so if I
throw someone in need even N I don't now
need to pin their arm that that's crazy
okay so there's a finality to the throws
or in the case of the PIN to the arm
break there's a finality to the arm
break your your Marshall Advantage goes
so way down now that you have one less
arm and all the pain that comes with
that arm okay and that's not generated
in IIT tyo there's no finality to to it
we want to see some
finality uh to the techniques okay any
questions now
okay um couple things go together no
forcing the technique so this means no
Yin Yong Clashing of any
kind
um equally then rule six the throws
should be
effortless and the metric for that is
hand weight should be ample just your
hand weight should do it if you have to
use any muscle or something you're in a
you're forcing the technique you
probably have a Yong Yong Clash going
and so you need more force uh and for
this kind of training uh due to its low
rate of acceleration and and its low
volume of inertia there's no reason why
you ever have to move past hand weight
okay if you are you're probably forcing
the technique you're probably having
Youngy clashing
okay
uh likewise if we come to 11 the Wasa
must be executed correctly well yyong
clashing is not part of the technique
that's an incorrect performance so you'd
be violating this rule too to
okay all right UK is never wrong in this
there's no such thing is bad or good
ukmi in
guaza um UK is not trying to do any um
prescription Beyond whatever the
parameters were if you say it's katat
DOI then they have to do katatori uh but
they decide how much spinal displacement
if any or they they pick all that kind
of stuff okay
okay
um they don't try to make your
techniques work so in that other
exercise where I'm just picking
techniques theuk always is letting me do
those techniques they are constantly and
be honest they're kind of trying to
figure out always which technique is are
they trying to do and as soon as they
figure out they position their body uh
in order for you to do that technique
okay so for
example if I'm if I'm here and
eventually he figures out that I'm going
to do teni nugget do you see that okay
so I'm going to do tension net and he
kind of leaned back for
me before I came in you see do you get
that and uh
that would be UK seeking agency he moved
his head back I didn't move his head
back okay
um and that is uh related to I have to
not expect UK to do anything for me so
whatever UK is doing is right okay so
yesterday you
had where you're trying to do
edaga but you're pulling the shoulder
down and the head comes with it do you
see and now you're trying to pick this
up now it's a y y Clash you get it okay
um it's not a USA's fault that his head
was down cuz the UK is never wrong and
it's not UK's
responsibility to position themselves
for your Technique once they identify
what technique it is because they should
never seek agency okay so have it in
your mind UK is never
wrong number eight everything counts
because
this starts to generate problems for the
person who's just picking techniques
okay uh because
no with UK having no
role to Harmon eyes or
Blend or reconcile the YY clashes or
identify my technique and fall a certain
way
eventually UK is not going to come in to
match the technique that you picked it
just happens all the time okay and so
you will get very
frustrated you're like here and I'm
taking you down and I'm trying to shove
you back you see and you're like uh okay
then you like stop and you'll start over
and it no you have to figure that out
you came here you realize you shouldn't
be clashing so you have to figure out
how to do something else without
breaking any of the rules you cannot
disengage and start over that is very
much akin
to
um if we're going to work on these two
minds you can't quit and you can't
Retreat and you can't disengage because
that's going to be your instinct okay
and so no everything counts you didn't
mess up UK didn't mess up you got to
figure this out
okay another rule is you're not allowed
to stop UK so every time you stop the UK
boom you just used one of your four
attempts that that's not not something
you you figure out you up you
stopped the UK the the the UK should let
go come back out and go they got three
more then it's my turn Okay anytime that
UK
stops um next one we already talked
about UK never seeks agency so equally
UK is not trying to counter my
techniques but UK is also not trying to
assist my techniques they're not not
trying to give my techniques they just
followed the
energy um that nag is is giving them
that's all they do okay um so for
example
um you uh enter turn and and C you
n ENT the arm turn and cook you nuget
okay so a lot of the UK will feel
that and then they take the
agency and they take the
roll as opposed to he's
going and they take that this is where
that UK would be if that had the
mechanical advantage to do that to them
okay they wouldn't go Topsy Turvy
because that would be agency okay
likewise in uh number 11 uh the Wasa has
to be cor correct again that also means
no Yong Yong clashing but it also
means that if you generated a Topsy
Turvy effect you actually had control of
the two Direct Control of the two distal
ends of the lever of the spine you have
to do that uh but it also means
where do your control points go in that
technique okay so for
example
um I am going to do a k Ash okay and I'm
not going to do K like this CU that's
it's not fingernail technique okay
that's not how I was taught so I don't
do it that way likewise I'm not going to
be in the wrist
either because I'm supposed to be in the
elbow right does that make sense or I'm
going to do um ID but I'm over here like
this do you see and I'm trying to turn
him into me that's not where that
control Point goes that's wrong uh
usually when I see that I just call it
that was one of your reps okay
techniques
wrong
um all right here are the we'll we save
these two cuz they're a little hard to
understand and we'll go to the last
one use the given inertia don't try to
accelerate to
generate um your momentum throws that's
going to fall under um ukia probably
sought energy if they took that forward
roll because you didn't have both sides
of the distal end of the spine to
actually generate the Topsy Turvy effect
um and you're probably going to force
the technique if you're trying to uh
over accelerate the UK so that they fall
in their cou net or what have you okay
you instead just use that
inertia um don't look to speed it up and
obviously don't look to slow it down
because you're probably going to stop
the UK that's incorrect except what is
actually there don't try to change it
okay all right these two do not pick the
technique so as I mentioned at the
beginning uh picking the
technique has just ego tripartite
functioning I am not in the moment uh I
am not doing WOAY I'm not allowing
things to reveal itself I am trying to
control what's happening uh which means
I'm afraid of what's Happening which
means I'm abiding in the darkness and
the delusion of s okay so I'm not
picking
techniques
eventually um I have a feeling that as
you guys try to do this it's going to
work fine you're going to go I'm picking
a
technique uh and I was able to take them
into the technique and that's Gaza again
it is not it's working because your UK
is seeking agency they try to identify
which technique you're doing and they
move their body to give you the opening
to make it seem like the technique is
being performed correctly and it's being
for performed effortlessly okay but it's
not eventually your ukia is going to get
a hold of the rules and go I just come
in and what happens happens
okay um and you're going to end up with
like Sean was ending up in the video
where he's pulling uh A's head down and
A's head went down and now it's not
going to come back up so now you're not
going to do any of the back inward or
outward kazushi patterns it's not going
to work okay and if you never get
there then when you come here you will
get there because our ukz will do that
to you okay we will do that to you and a
good way of looking at it was the
difference of how how Taylor was the UK
for aush in that video versus how sha
and Maya were UK for each other in that
video and I mentioned that with a
subtitle okay so check that out um we're
not picking a technique there's I'm not
picking it beforehand there's no way I'm
picking it beforehand
so what we're doing is when we're here I
I am not going
into tensi Nugget for example so pay
attention he came in and I and I went
like that you see that okay so I haven't
yet felt his energy do you see that
okay what was I prescribed to do grabb
your two wrist okay so you're going to
do that movement
before right you got to do it before you
pick it
okay that that's what this UK should do
does that make sense UK doesn't go
here for this
thing the UK comes in he gets the wrist
this is what that looks like now
okay so I can't be ahead where I get
here there is just I touch the wrist
okay and you see that's not the
technique now and the only way to do it
is I got to do something not real two
steps to one step right that's not real
okay
or right I do it again get in that weird
position and I start forcing
it
but what happened before that you sto do
you see so I can't do that t
uh it's going to break one of the other
rules sooner or later as long as the UK
obeys their rules don't seek agency
don't give me my technique just do the
prescription okay um the only way I can
do this is he touches me and I feel what
he's doing so just stay where you are
this hand has a lot of
energy and it has a slight turn to it in
other words it's not going this way okay
and it has more energy than this hand do
you see so I have to use that I know I
can't stop you and I know I can't force
you right do you get it so I have to use
that energy there it is and that's what
I use this has a lot of down you wanted
to go back but it had a lot of down so I
have to use
that instead okay
so if you
are moving before
touched you're
picking if your UK is
moving to get you where you need to be
you're picking because there was nothing
wrong with where the UK was was okay the
only reason he had to move back is
because I wanted his head to go back
instead of where was his head going
instead do you see you'll break all
kinds of rules as you start picking but
just like the Zed master who you learn
the answer to the
Coan right uh why did bodh Dharma come
from the west and you're all move and he
already knows you're a ego
tripartite robot it doesn't matter that
you had the right answer they're going
to be able to tell you don't have the
reconciliation of the two minds okay um
but if you play long enough with this
you too will be able to tell okay
likewise then just like in the diamond
Sutra it's both it's neither you can't
pick you also can't unpick you can't go
thisi keeps putting me in Shon I need to
do a different one that's unpicking no
just work with the energy that's
happening as it's happening okay that's
the difference here um you
might want to say
that isn't the point of
guaza to do kihon waza no no the point
is not to do kihon waza um
which is why if you pay
attention uh if you start doing it right
you'll almost never do Kona you'll
almost never do it you you'll also have
techniques that you won't remember which
ones you did uh you will have never done
them before you will not uh ever do them
again probably okay now and that is
entirely different from I'm picking my
techniques and I'm just trying to be
spontaneous with my techniques that's
not being spontaneous with techniques
that's just thinking real fast with the
ego tripartite mind okay that's
something entirely different so uh one
of the techniques that uh I didn't
really understand how I did it I don't
even know how I could get in it right
now to tell you the truth um let's see I
think it was in the block of the video
where I was showing the mistake of
turning a us here you remember that one
okay and I was all like well when he
turns then their technique is
here and that's there's no Keyon W on
that there's no technique like that
we've never done that um you're not
picking techniques you're transcending
form you're reconciling form and non
form and that's not a matter of picking
techniques or trying to do techniques or
even trying to be spontaneous with
techniques you're trying to transcend
the dichotomy of form and non form if we
use the word transcendence or
spontaneous you're spontaneous with the
art not not like EO or no
everything that is EO would have to be
justified in the guaza training for it
to be EO
um so for
example uh I say I'm going to do this
one right I have to be able to feel that
I don't I will not be able to get his
Center like he there has to be weight on
that you get what I'm saying so that I
would attack the
arm and as as I attack the arm there has
to be weight here too because if it's
limp
just limp go limp and I'll just kick him
in the face because it has to be
real having being here on a limp arm and
trying to be limp and trying to get this
arm is not real okay this is real
technique over right and then when I get
down to the end if I get down there I
can't do that stupid pin because it's
not a real pin so I have to figure out
what I'm going to do
instead right
I'll never do EO in Gaza there's very
very few techniques that I do so take
for
example another one
was um I was demonstrating to Virginia
that if you're going to do the tenom
version of iag you don't tilt the head
that's incorrect this has to go through
the
spine and then he has to come up well
now it's kind of
goofy right if he's
down I should come in here and do my
stuff from here that's where I should go
I don't want to
pick techniques let alone those
techniques that require you to do a what
if that's not
in the situation here to the point we're
not trying to be spontaneous with
techniques we're not trying to pick them
ahead of time time we're trying to free
ourselves from form not just pick form
and do them quickly